okay hi everyone welcome to another
orphan language design review
part of our incremental language
development
and
lots of throat clearing and let's get
going
um
okay
first up
real value numeric cue what is this
right so you know we've had for a long
time an internal function
uh real value numeric Q which tests that
something is both numeric U and that the
value will be oh you know a real you
know real integer rational not
um you know not something complex valued
and well you know there's been some talk
about making this a system function and
it has become I think sort of more
important with the recent change to M so
in 13 to an earlier if you took M of a
machine reel you got
exact zero
and now it gives a machine zero
and how's that blown things up or I mean
we don't know
there were some changes in the startup
code uh uh particularly where it's using
uh exactly that example the aim of
something is the same cue of an exact
zero and that was previously the best
way to test that something was uh
like real valued
but double equals will still work is
that correct absolutely absolutely well
yes and no I mean it would give true but
it would also give true to something
that's you know complex with a small
imaginary no zero has no tolerance
no no but it does it does get true it's
the complex number has an exact zero uh
a machine Zero part it will be zero
so there's some fuzz and the and no
there's there's no there's no fuzz
around zero for for a quality to zero
the fuzz the problem with using equals
zero and and this this function possibly
has that that problem too the same
problem is that if x is you know say the
special Trot zero which is a hidden zero
then it can take time to to evaluate
all right let me be let me understand
what you're saying so go ahead
right so
okay I mean I think I'm going to just
if I say this
okay that's an exact zero because it's
uh
oh sorry I meant times I
I haven't now if now if I do this is two
point
of how far do I have to go before it
or
let's see this
equals equals zero is false right
what's the confusing case
well so
aim of a complex number yeah right mob
two point plus zero point I equals
equals exact zero
now exactly 0.0 point and that's it
0.1 no one 0.0
uh-huh LIC equals zero that's correct
yeah
yeah but this
that's also correct correct okay but
what isn't correct is triple equals here
right right
and that was in the previous version
that would give true no no
yes that would give true
because the the M would evaluate to an
exact zero let's take it no no no no no
no no no no not that okay
that's right yeah
it might be easier if you do it without
the same queue to see yeah
I mean this is where it would break but
it's just you yes when it's returning
right so that that is now
why is that in the exact zero so maybe
that your version the thing on the right
is
okay yeah yeah so yeah so that is the
change and the reason the reason for
this Stephen is because
like before we we used to have just one
machine Precision type so the machine
real number but in the compiler we have
a real 32 we have a real 64 we have a
real 16.
um and we also have all these different
integer types too like an integer 8 into
16 which is six people we want the m to
return the same type as the as the real
number so that we it's type consistent
not not previously it would return
machine integer zero which is kind of
not very useful it doesn't tell you
anything about the type of the real part
so
this makes me nervous but if it isn't
blowing things up in 13 3 then I guess
it's okay
well it blew things up because of this
change
and but what you can do to use a code
well any user who's using this test of
you know
for this test
same Q of M to see how much same qm
there is
I don't know how we scan users
Public public code
I think our node has ways to do that
let's try to not give somebody some
Insidious bug of code that's worked for
30 years and stops working please
I mean that's one reason to provide a
function like we have no it's not a
reason to provide a function it's a
reason to not change what we already
have the only way we're not going to
blow up code is to not change what we
already have
so you know honestly your explanation
for why we want this it's a kind of a
mild nice to have but if it's going to
blow up a bunch of code we shouldn't
make the change
it's too Insidious to change
I mean I understand your reason for
wanting it it's well and good but let's
find out whether it's going to blow up
code because I think you know you have a
hypothesis this is the only
well okay yeah please let's find out
whether it's going to blow up code and
let's understand what was the code that
already blew up in the startup system
well I think we've understood that well
what is it what's the answer it's
exactly this is
where was it used
was it used in something was a system
level thing or was it used in code that
was kind of reasonable user level code
I don't know what that means
I'm asking was it only used in something
which was essentially meta programming
of some kind which we can expect that
only our startup packages would do or
was it used in just some random
mathematical you know function setup
right it was used in stats for example
and what
statistics startup code MX code
just kind of blow things up this is
going to lead to some horrible Insidious
bug
I mean I think right and the thing you'd
imagine someone's doing it they're just
trying to test if their number is real
yeah
which is not a particularly meta
programming thing but this is not a good
way to do that this is uh Tom I don't
know
we can't okay
yeah let me just introduce a better
function and we can revert the old
Behavior so the old code doesn't break
but can we have a more literate way to
express this idea rather than the rather
fragile that's fine yeah I'm all in
favor of that but I think we can't break
existing code it's just I mean what what
we could do as a compromise is introduce
these functions say that they're more
descriptive more efficient as well
because like this in okay fine and same
queue is doing two things one is doing
an action on a real number creating a
complex we can encourage people to use
the new functions yeah and then we can
maybe review this in a couple of
versions that sounds fine I should
revert the change and let's figure out
how to make a nice shiny new function
that does this okay I think that's what
these two functions do real value number
queue and real value numerically so real
value number Q is just the predicate it
just looks at the type of the number and
that's it super fast
why isn't it called real cue yeah yeah
well there's a I mean there's a
difference between
I mean right well real number Q is
different from real valued numeric you
right so I understand it real numeric
you and real number Q is what you're
suggesting no I'm not suggesting real
another job assistant real cute because
why isn't it the same as integer Q is it
isn't it doing the same because integers
will also be valued right
right I get it I I mean it's real in the
sense
yeah floating Point rational and no no
no no no no the point you're making is
it's real in the sense of having zero
imaginary part rather than real and
sensible being a real data type right
that's why the valued is in the name
yeah I don't understand how we can have
a function real value numeric queue
because I can always give you a number
that's really valued and you there's no
decisive procedural to decide if it's
real
zero
so it might give
must give a mathematically correct
answer
the case you're talking about though is
something where it's like it's in some
complicated symbolic form and you can't
decide whether the No No not symbolic
because it's it's all number Q like I
take cosine of 2 pi over 65 537 number
two that's that's numeric you that's
what I'm saying
wait a second already with greater than
is it or double equals right I can make
a this is not Q it doesn't have to
decide I see
I mean
I mean numeric you doesn't actually
guarantee that the thing will
end up being numeric and not exactly I
mean numeric you can fail too
is not is top level now I can't remember
yeah yeah okay impossible zero cues
already something that can fail so this
this is basically possible zero queue of
the imaginary part right yeah
well so it could be it could be possible
real cue
but I think
I mean another thing would be do we make
a distinction between numeric queue and
number Q where number Q is more surface
level yes
so we could have a real number Q instead
of uh real numeric queue or whatever it
was yeah
and it's not but number Q is not true
for pi is it right that's correct yeah
because number Q is literally you know
integer red or real or complex
I made that point in the agenda that we
do have a real valued number Q which we
could also have a system as a system
function but that's really sugar because
that's really just number q and head is
not complex it's
useful in in things like array queue or
Matrix Q or vector Q yeah yeah right and
and there those cases are optimized for
those functions
yeah yeah so so when I went through the
startup code the graphics guys were
really happy to get rid of this test in
of something number is equal equal zero
because when they do their array
processing and using the real value
number queue now that's super optimized
and so their their pre-processing of
like you know pack the race and stuff
got more efficient
all right well look I think I mean I
don't see we have any choice about the
name real valued number Q I think that's
about all we can do it's a bit ugly but
I think that's all we can do because of
the horrible hakalola of uh half a
century ago that real
means
you know floating point
um I the dedicant will be rolling over
and whatever you know it's reals and not
floating point they're just oh whatever
I don't know I don't even know what that
it's a yes it's not our abuse so to
speak it was a 50-year ago abuse not due
to us
um
the only question I see real value
number q and then real value numeric Q
with Michael's objection that the
numeric queue is undecidable
yeah but it could be just a question of
documentation we can definitely decide
that it's
a you know evaluatable as a real
expression
yeah
there are any number of functions which
when they can't make a decision they say
you know can't decide if this is exactly
zero assuming it is or assuming it isn't
that typically yes they assume it is and
so we could issue a message
yes but only a small number of them have
a cure that
right although the queue has escaped to
be a little bit as impossible zero queue
yeah
I don't think we have any pattern for
something like this
um
because numeric queue which also has
this problem we could hide a zero
multiplying an X in something right it
could be a number plus a hidden zero
times x and then numeric Q is
um
uh but but realize numeric you gives
false false answers to try numeric Q of
sine of one two yeah exactly
foreign
like this yeah
right
because it has had numeric q and only
an only numeric arguments so
it assumes it will evaluate that number
but it doesn't and and also you know
things that generate exceptions you know
are hidden one over zero that's going to
bring an infinitive or indeterminate or
you know I mean there are all sorts of
exceptions to that all right so look I I
think I'm agreeing with your proposal
here I think number one we have to
revert the the M thing
but number two we have real num real
value number q and real value numeric Q
okay it's right to me
I like those
okay
onward we go I'm I'm recognizing
Michael's objection which is valid but
difficult
um I guess that there's one other
question of shouldn't it I still have a
comment like if you read The Ref page of
numerical numericu does not say
something is numeric it gives the clear
decision procedure based on heads
numeric function attribute and such
things and destroyed answer so the upper
documentation of really valued numerical
is the little Channel yeah so what's it
gonna say
cannot say that something is real
because it's it must do some quite
different things
like numerical does not say something is
numeric it says a certain number of
conditions description okay it's a
numeric quantity
which has been determined to be real
and false otherwise
yep that's that's great which and if it
hasn't been determined
then
all right let's go on to the next topic
if we can
um some of us are not in the agenda for
other topics so yeah fine sounds good
bye bye thanks for joining us yeah see
ya
okay
okay all right we got quite a long way
with this bibliographic references stuff
a while ago
um
what happened to it
to my knowledge we last discussed this
in the third live ceoing live stream and
in the intermediate time we've added
external identifier which is a component
that's needed good one you mean like 500
back or something
back in 2017. episode three
and when 2017. yep
wow
okay
well we've got evidence so external
identifier I believe came out of that
and this is now revisiting the
references specifically
okay
so
Michael and others uh who who's here to
comment on this who's there to talk
about this
okay
I mean Michael do you support us trying
to do this
I I think there are two two components
one having the
the structure in the
notebooks I strongly support this the
more interesting one is have this really
as a convenient workflow in the front
end
right I mean I'll give you an example
you know I have been you know we've made
some bibliographies for I've made some
bibliographies for you know combinators
second order of thermodynamics things
like this
and I would like to have had some way to
do it like this it would have been very
nice
and I mean I you know I wasn't using bib
Tech or anything like this I was just
doing it raw in a notebook so so can I
comment that workflow is describing
citations which are basically things you
embed in a document that point to a
reference yep um The Proposal here was
to focus on the language design for
references but we do have John if we
need to discuss citations
reference versus a citation a citation
is something that you actually put in
your sentence it's like a one or
whatever and it links to oh I see I see
it in the bibliography
the other one is the usage
reference in your yeah I got it I got it
I mean the the bibliographies I've been
making don't have that kind of micro
referencing
so but your point is there's got to be a
way to footnote something in the flowing
document inconveniently
reference items and then conveniently
with audio completion also a selector
well it's also not just selecting them
because the citation might include
something like a page number
foreign
well no I mean like presumably you want
one bibliographic reference for you know
whatever thing you're you know a book
and then you want many citations
pointing different pages of that one
reference yep I think it depends like
for example like in entity stores when
we have lots of definitions each one you
kind of want a symbolic representation
for the reference and and that usually
includes a page number
okay so let's just understand even
roughly the book itself is a separate
entity I think adding being able to add
a page number like like reference one
comma page 715 or something would be you
know some people like to do that not
everybody but some people like to do
that but there's also a whole a whole
you know structure do you cite the page
do you cite the chapter do you cite the
addition do you say or like you know the
volume
if it's a movie do you cite you know the
the minute Mark when the thing happened
you know whatever
yes I mean look there's a lot of I've
discovered this in in things that I've
tried to do there's a lot of modern
media where traditional citation is
pretty silly
I mean let's be realistic the actual
thing you want is a URL you can click on
you know all the other stuff is just for
window dressing
I mean it's magnificent and it's kind of
interesting to see but it is not
depends on the context
it for scholarly stuff where the
mathematician wants to see where it came
from so he can go and verify it that you
didn't pull the wool over his eyes he
wants to see what about a link
well what if it's a movie right you're
citing a movie and you're saying minute
36 or it's a book that's you know not in
print or something you scroll down
online a list of of like kind of
brainstorm types we might want to have I
didn't I'll show you an example this is
a real example this is an actual
bibliography
okay and well this one is a very old
line subject which won't have a lot of
modern stuff in it so I mean
this is
this is also one that you made that
that's going to be you know have all the
restrictions of the way you made it
right you were just saying that you made
it yeah I know exactly like this has
some nice stuff like independently
published which is
non-standard non-published you need a
way to be able to say that kind of thing
private node private communication
that it says independent published I bet
we got that from the I bet we asked them
how to cite that
weird funky
well I I think stuff like that is
usually specified in like the style of
guides
like like if you read it if you go to
like modern uh you know citation
generators and stuff like that they'll
have like 50 different types of things
you can cite
right I mean this stuff is very weird
here I mean this is
okay I mean what what that is I don't
know what that is could you give a
string template as one of the properties
to inform how to format the thing for
certain types yes but it's all it's
already complicated so
the other thing I've got here
sorry is it is it another kind of worms
here probably as translations which is
another complicated thing
I mean I was gonna say I I think so
right I mean I think generating
citations is usually a lot more
complicated than that I mean it might be
worth looking at like how big Tech or
something does this because you know bib
Tech they have like
probably on the order of like a hundred
different citation or you know uh
bibliography Styles and I'm sure they
have some representation of them and of
course they have a representation of the
items that are being referenced and so
on so
it might be worth looking at that well
is this might be worth even calling out
to it yeah because I just it seems like
it's really
Okay so we've got
one is the upstart think which is in
some sense always the same article book
or whatever and the other one how it's
formatted and I think the two should
stay distinct indeed yes I mean this is
if I might say so kind of nonsense what
they've got here I mean this is this is
an utterly inadequate the 14 bib Tech
entry types is utterly inadequate
well but that's the base thing about
like article versus book versus whatever
but I think it goes well now where's the
video
it's all it's all just miscellaneous
yeah so that in in the agenda notebook
I've I've put together a list of of more
like modern types of things that we want
to reference
um
but I think it would be good before we
got one we can drop
no I'm completely serious I'm not
completely serious no no no we should
keep it I'm not I'm not serious I'm just
I'm just I'm I'm like they're dying
um
yeah so I think it would be helpful if
we went through the current situation
section where I have the different kind
of entity examples that we have
currently
pretty varied
okay but I'm still trying to ask the
question so I I see so you're imagining
that it's a type of essentially external
identifier
I'm imagining external identifiers can
appear inside a bibliographical
reference I see what you're saying
yes you know in the end
you know in here for example
realistically if I'm going to go there
okay that was nice
you know I just want to click something
that often you can't yeah I know like
like in these ones I can't this one it
is unclickable
foreign
I mean right it seems like probably it's
just you want to have some kind of uh
you know sort of bibliographic reference
representation that's you know similar
to how bib Tech works for basically you
just have whatever keys and values you
happen to have
and you just you know fill in as much as
you want and then separately there's a
mechanism for actually converting it
into a string right yeah I want to just
bring people's attention to the first
few citations here look at these yeah so
like if you include the DOI key then it
should have potentially look at this
kind of one of those but what's
happening here in this citation
we've got the thing it's in German we
got the translation of the title we've
got where you can find the translated
version of it that looks like a page
range before the DOI
yeah that's a page range right but but
look at this the fact that there's a
translation of the title for example
which is useful obviously right I mean
this is this is I think this is very
standard stuff in modern times and these
things are just generated automatically
like I don't know what the okay all
right you know
okay well so then the question is could
we just use
okay the question is could we just use
bibtek for example
the last step it'll probably Beyond bib
tech for the large tint of things that
fall under miscellaneous
well I mean like for example if you want
a deep link into a notebook that's a
non-trivial thing
I mean okay let's zoom out for a second
I mean part of what we are trying to do
which we've been trying to do for 25
years is sort of the computational
publication story
right where you know we've got
traditional publishing we've got
building for the future
and so whatever we do here better work
for building for the future
so for example one thing we don't have
and maybe John fultz could comment on
this is Anchor here's a question how do
you make an anchor link into a notebook
on the cloud
or not on the cloud is it strong with us
or not Yeah Yeah by anchor link you mean
a link to a particular cell yeah let me
show you I mean like like in you know
for example okay if we go to your
average you know random thing I've
written
um
you know here right
this has a table of contents here and
this here
has you know has that hash sign URL
do what I'm saying yeah
so it Links at least to this level and
we're actually planning to link even
further down to these individual things
um
uh okay
sorry I'm sorry I'm just I'm just trying
to remember what's actually been done
here and I'm refreshing myself on that
uh
um yeah I I don't know if there's uh
uh a way in the cloud to kind of create
a URL scheme that does that but there's
nothing in our hyperlink interface that
will that would try to like automate
that for you in any way
um
all right so I think this is a this is
an issue we should address but it's a
separate issue from these issues in
other words it should be the case that
you can link to a section for example in
it that we can generate
I mean in the cloud for example I mean
if I were to take this notebook right
and I were to
you know let's say I
you know published a cloud
to Anonymous URL
why is that thing not why is it sort of
splattering why is it why is it not
oh for goodness sake why is this not
just working
why is it spinning that's not a big
notebook is it yeah
um
I don't know it's not a big notebook
why did that happen what was going on
there I don't know
okay so here we have this notebook right
so what we want to be able to do here
you know really what we want is in the
right click menu
where's the where are the gears do we
not have gears in in this view it's
published
you don't get gears in a published
notebook if I recall correctly
right you're you're not logged are you
even logged in I don't know you whether
you're logged in or not but yeah this is
a read-only notebook so
yeah okay
yeah well I mean on the web it's
surprisingly painful to get the uh URL
for a particular element you know you
have to go into the inspector and so on
right
but but here
I mean it could be in the I don't know
that doesn't make any sense it could be
in the share menu right it could be in
the share or something there
that's what I'm saying I mean if there
was a now that you have unique IDs for
cells it seems like it should be
possible to just put a you know hash
sign blah blah blah thing there
all right angry in principle it might it
might even be possible in practice I'm
just not aware of how it's done if it's
possible if you know the expression uuid
you can use that as an anchor in the URL
or if it has cell tags or cell ID you
can use those as well I put a example
Link in the in the chat
in that case I used to sell tag
and so this worked
yeah I had to insert that cell tag into
that cell though otherwise it would be a
weird yeah so if we can expose that ID
um
okay so there's this question of how do
we expose how do we get the uh cell ID
so okay so you're basically saying this
has already been built
but we need to make sure that it has a
proper interface
am I making sense yeah yeah I think so
so I think this is a discussion with
also the cloud team and we maybe we
should tackle this in user systems is
that the right place for it John uh yes
okay we should start live streaming some
of those user assistance meetings there
or not
whatever
people if everybody's watching this who
has an opinion about that they can
express it
um
okay
uh
um what's the thing Brad has just put in
the URL
chat for the Library of Congress
um yeah I was just thinking about cases
when we don't have links directly to the
document if there's going to be a
secondary like Online Library Source
saying at least that these books exist
it's just not just a
figment of imagination made up by some
chat bot
ha ha
that's a modern problem isn't it yes
yeah sorry another example along that
line is like a pre-print of a paper
you might not have access to the
published paper
that you can get your hands on but there
might be something on archive
well well I don't know that's kind of
different than what I was talking about
because with the with the pre-prints you
click the link and you're can directly
in the document you can get all the
information but then for like these old
books and things they might be stuck in
a library somewhere or yeah yeah but
basically Brad is saying it will be nice
to have a proof of existence
even if you can't even if it is only
like the DOI in a sense provides a proof
of existence but older documents don't
have dois
if it's a valid DOI not one that's made
up
I understand but but any of these things
you can make up a Library of Congress
identifier
right but you can't make up but you
cannot make up the actual record at the
Library of Congress exactly it's like a
blockchain you know it's it's like hey
you know it it is a ledger that you know
it's like a title deed it's like any of
these things where there's a central
you know a repository I see there are
two Library of Congress identifier types
I don't know what they are
Authority ID and control number yeah
those are standard
Library science things
um okay but that's a that's a separate
issue it's an interesting thing
okay let's take a look at what your so
okay one question is how do you insert
the little footnote you know ones and
things
is that addressed here or is that not
no I would say that's that's the insert
citation menu item which I have listed
under Integrations
okay
okay but but so hold on a second so so
the typical workflow would be you
maintain this great big file
I mean for bib Tech files do people just
like have a file on their desktop
basically that is is there collection of
references
academical type people can you tell me
that
Eric um that was my least favorite part
of writing a dissertation
because it's hard it's difficult to keep
all of the bibliographic information in
its most standard form
but roughly what do people do do they
have a file called dot bib Tech that is
just a big list of things and they just
add things to it yeah or possibly more
than one file you might have a file
that's specific to one chapter or
article that you're working on wait wait
wait
some people do write the the or or you
know they're sort of dedicated bib Tech
managers to help you
you know keep track of your okay so they
it sits in a database somewhere and for
example you can tell oh how many times
have I cited this paper in in my last 50
papers or something is that the type of
thing
there are some people who do that yes
like oh I haven't cited my friend enough
times in my last end papers let me give
let me throw in a citation in this one
but
am I too cynical
um
uh
okay but but so I mean it is standard
practice I believe for people to
maintain you know I have my file of
references
yep right and then to cite something
from that file of references there are
presumably bib Tech managers that you
can just go and click something and that
will copy the
reference in the right form to put in
your paper is that correct
yep but the thing that goes in your
paper is not in any way symbolic it is
literally the the series of characters
that make the citation in the correct
format is that correct
no no it's it's it's a pointer to the
database
so that okay so that you know when you
compile it the style of your article
dictates how that
entry is formatted in your paper I see
so so like for example for us a date
object for example might be rendered in
different ways depending on your
preferences even though it's the same
date object underneath is that right
sure
and in this case
it's kind of like we've got or names you
know first name last name right I I
understand I understand but the point
that I'm saying here is that what you're
saying is that in the notebook there
will be a thing that isn't
actual if you looked at the Box form of
the thing it would be
okay what happens if you uh drag select
over a piece of a reference
in a notebook where you have a reference
being given
what happens when you drag select do you
get the characters that you actually see
or do you get something different or can
you not drag select it
when you drag select what wait the
rendered citation okay
well well
so I mean in in in a useful system of
the sort that I think we're talking
about
uh you wouldn't be able to uh you
probably wouldn't be able to edit such a
thing in place because you know it's a
constructed thing okay that's what I'm
that's what I'm trying to understand so
this would be so if I if this was a
rendered thing if I if I drag selected
just wouldn't select well it might
select I'm not saying you wouldn't be
able to like copy text out of it or
something like that but if you try to
type into it it would just reject your
keystrokes
okay fine
okay
so
what what do we have that's like the
traditional form is not like that
click the hyperlink editor might be
something
relevant so if you Mouse over it maybe
there's a little
button the pops up to edit the values
yes
um can you scroll up in the notebook and
look at the entity store examples
I guess it's down actually
um yeah Publications
so I think for me there's two two
different use cases there's like the
bibliography at the end of your notebook
and then there's having these things as
values of properties and entity stores
yes okay so if you think at the end of
your notebook is a selection from here
that is rendered as text yeah so if you
look at the next section you'll see some
examples of of how we've been doing
references
and it's kind of different for each
entity type
and then also there's a separate there's
usually a separate property that has
these things formatted as like rows and
things like that
okay so you're saying
that the proposed idea is
that there is a bibliographic reference
and I'm not even sure we should do that
of having a base type there I don't
think there's anything very bass about
that type I think that all the
properties should be able to be mixed
and matched
because I think there's the things which
are barely a book is it a book as a
pamphlet is it a poster is it a postcard
is it a you know it's a it's a you know
it's a it's one of those things that's
like uh you know how Maps sometimes fold
out and they have a little booklet
around them what the heck is that
so in bib Tech the like 13 standard uh
publication types have different
selections of required and optional Keys
okay so that's saying I think that
that's interesting are they all optional
for us yeah I think it's old news I
think that that I think that we need to
just have something like that's a soup
of keys and we Define I mean again we
should have asked somebody like Aaron
who's actually you know librarian
oriented
um
but what I would suggest I mean there
are many attempts like whether it's the
Dublin core thing or whatever else to
standardized all this stuff I think that
you know I think it's a moving Target
and I think
that
um
my suggestion in modern times would be
that it's just a big Association and we
try and standardize the keys in the
association we say here are some
reasonable keys
am I making sense
do you understand what I'm saying
we don't have a base type because I
don't think it's going to work
we have a convention that if you say
type Arrow book these keys are required
am I making sense
um
okay I don't even think we need you know
like author may not be possible there
may not be an obvious author
who's the author of
I don't know
the UN Charter or something
does it have an author I don't know does
it have a
what's the answer to that
I mean I don't know there's probably
some fake citation thing that people put
in there
well they'd give the publisher right
which would I know they wouldn't the
author I'm asking the author not the
publisher the author
it would probably be listed as not as a
person but the you know whatever
committee
right committee or organization is all
right okay what happens if you want to
cite
a um what happens if you want to cite
Stonehenge
or do you not get to cite that
what happens if you want to cite a or or
is Stonehenge just
falling under an external identifier
no what happens if you want to cite a
there aren't any tablet so it's
Stonehenge but you know let's say there
were
okay
okay so you you put okay fine
you wrote that a stone Maybe
that's a good one
yeah you might cite that I would think
why wouldn't you cite that sure
either author unknown or you'd be citing
something other than the Rosetta Stone
itself for instance an early document
about it exactly yes which is commonly
done indeed
right
but I think it's more okay but so look
my point is just
okay it's bibliographic reference just
becomes an association Then There are
rules for how to pick up the keys from
the associations or render it in
different forms does that make sense to
people
yep it seems straightforward I mean this
seems like the obvious thing to do
now
and in terms of
you know
manipulating bibliographic references
presumably there are certain functions
that we need for that I mean presumably
that can be turned into a data set
presumably it has sub values that turn
it into various kinds of things this is
all on the agenda if you want to go back
okay well fine
where is it
there's properties and there's
well so first we have the different
ideas like so for example etai suggested
we might want to have different kinds of
buttons for whether you want to copy
just the plain text or copy a text cell
yeah
I would think so
okay
the question is this like uh is this
like an entity
and it's it's way of choosing a label or
it's more like an external right which
has an external identifier has a
why did you have those here up here
that has an appearance right I don't
remember how that's done don't go back
down to where you were
um an example there
The Entity external identifier
under formatting ideas
right so without the label you just get
the ID you specify
drop the label
I said what do you mean about the label
what oh without the label I get it
right so I mean this citation thing
could be another thing that is similar
the
similar to external identifier
as is that what you're proposing
what are you proposing here I I
don't know that I'm okay so I'm gonna
propose something I think it should be
you know first of all I don't think it
can I think if it has a styling it has
to be a very light styling because I
don't think people want a big you know
big boxes around every reference
am I making sense
look what it should do is the thing
should format that okay bibliographic
reference should format in some
reasonable way based on some you know
you can presumably set some Global style
for your bibliographic references just
like you can set a global style for your
dates am I making sense
how do you set the style for dates
your date string format sets them
globally
right okay I knew there was a way to do
that okay
so
you know a similar thing could be used
to build graphic references you set it
in that form
like a dollar bibliographical reference
format yes for example
and that will be the default way that
they would display in The Notebook
am I making sense
yeah
should probably be something that can be
said on a paired notebook basis too
right
maybe it comes from the style sheet I
mean maybe you can have it set from the
style sheet
John would that be possible
yes
it's just basically template box
Define
okay so then
Okay so
that's how it would display
and but what operations do you want to
do on it so you might have you know
there's some backing database
that has this stuff okay what happens if
I want to suck a bib Tech
something from my bib Tech
citation manager thing
into a notebook we used to have like 30
years ago didn't we have what was the
name of that thing uh I think import of
a DOT bib file should just give a list
of bibliographical references fine but
we we used to have a thing Pro site
right we used to have some kind of link
to Pro site did we not
nobody knows about this we had a a link
to endnotes okay maybe that was the
thing
um okay so what what how did that work
or does it still work no it uh I mean
the feature is still there but it's no
it's not really in in good shape right
now and I we haven't even tried to track
more recent versions of endnote so it's
probably what was that we're just going
to take out yeah insert uh there's a
citation menu oh wow
and we had supported endnote and Bid
Tech here but this is code that's not
been maintained for a long time nobody's
good
and I believe it was Windows only
uh and endnote was Windows only Bid Tech
was cross-platform oh okay what does
this do
what did this do so in principle what it
did was it uh you would uh there I don't
I don't recommend trying to use it I've
tried and it doesn't work right now but
uh in principle what it did was you
would set your master bibliography file
uh database uh you know weather endnote
or bib Tech
and then uh you know it would have a
little kind of scrolly interface that
you could bring up to say you know I
want to I want to find a reference and I
want to plop it here and it would it
would uh uh you know set up a uh you
know the the superscript type reference
and then there would be an automatically
managed uh uh section at the end of your
notebook which would be the list of
references in you know that were
consumed and it's very actionable
distancing can you click a one you can
click the one uh it didn't work
there oh
yes it did work so if you look this is
actually a reference cell and the
earlier one was an inline citation cell
wow okay
so there's a whole mechanism for this
there I mean I hate this action of
distance thing
am I making sense I mean is there
something better we could do in modern
times it seems incredibly well I mean I
mean I mean there are two actions
there's you know there's an action
exactly where you're at and then there's
a secondary action at a distance
just in case you're not clear on that
well what what if what if this one thing
was a direct type of I mean hyperlinks
you know in some ways hyperlinks all the
modern references you know in the past
you just didn't want you know look some
journals you would put you know
reference to Smith 1972 or something
um right but but the notion was that you
wanted to you know I mean you know at
the at the end of your notebook you
would have a list of the references that
were used in this notebook
yeah I understand I understand I'm
asking very old school I mean because in
modern times why not have every
reference just be a hyperlink
to the external things that's your
reference so the other use case you know
for an entity you know what's the
reference for this theorem
you know it's it's a value returned from
a property
okay I mean I mean I don't think it's
that old school it's how Wikipedia works
yeah I know
I know it's how academic stuff works
right but I mean how academic is
Wikipedia
well there's a different thing there
which is more like the bibliography of
mine that I was showing which is a
bibliography that you are expected to
read
and I think that that has some value I
mean you know in in the Wikipedia
context I mean I mean I've done this you
know sometimes in the Wikipedia case I
you know I see a specific citation and I
want to go and look at it but sometimes
I just want to go and look at the whole
list of citations just to see where
they're coming from yeah
that has value oh it has value yes it's
a very scurrilous value but it has value
it can get very scurrilous
and you know I mean I think that you
know in terms of you know yes you
shouldn't you know cribbage your stuff
directly off of Wikipedia but you know
what Wikipedia is a great place to you
know start to get a list of sources if
you don't know the Wikipedia editors
don't take down the best sources because
they happen to not like the people
well it was yeah I mean you know
political issues aside it's you know the
uh the point being if it's an area that
I don't know anything about and I'm
looking for the first approximation
yeah so
it feels very bizarre to me to do
something which which in our kind of
world that just goes you know like like
to me
multi-pane notebooks are vastly more
important than some weird thing with
references where you stick stuff at the
end
I mean it just
just seems very you know yes it was a
fine thing to do on paper and yes people
do it imitating paper on the web
but it just seems like a really
old-school thing to do
and it doesn't seem obvious to me and it
seems like it's fraught with
difficulties
for us like I mean what's the new school
just links
so I just I never get to see the
totality of I agree because it's useful
sometimes to see that totality
I just think it's it's I don't know I
think the idea that you stick the things
sort of on paper at the end and you're
having many-to-one mappings where you
can have the same thing cited multiple
times but only you know where it's a a
seven and the Seven appears multiple
times in the document pointing down to
the same lump of of material at the
bottom
you know
I I'm just surprised we can't come up
with a I I don't know maybe this is the
only way to do it maybe this is the the
you know
it's um
it shows a reference on a tool tip yeah
rather than possible yeah and and I
think that kind of what you're talking
about is really about citations and I
think references are still useful
independent of citations
what you're saying is something a little
bit like what we have in plots where you
have legended versus labeled versus call
out Etc et cetera et cetera
it's the same type of thing I mean
Legend is another action of distance way
of indicating something in a plot
and making sense
that makes sense yeah it's less distance
yes it's less distant but it's still not
right there unlike labeled which is
right there
but not everybody has it at the end
especially it's a history books have a
typically at the bottom of the page yes
indeed
and that's that's another thing I use I
read history books and that's another
thing I use all the time and yes so do I
I read the footnotes more than I read
the main text often
but what's your point I mean we don't
have Pages here right
no but but bottom can be right right
hand side
yes well if we had pains that's exactly
what we could do
you know have notes in the right sidebar
type thing
I don't know that would look good but
but I mean I haven't seen people do that
but that seems like a possible thing to
do
well to be clear I'm not fighting for a
particular location I'm fighting for
the ability to see the summary
fine I I don't disagree about that
I'm just saying I okay let's go back to
the original point which was having some
bibliographic reference symbolic object
and then the question is what operations
do you do on that other than display it
I think one important one would be
out of completion so calls to course ref
and other places
so we had a mechanism for that we were
looking at a few years ago where you
give
um
uh
you know where
you give some reference that's sort of
messy and it goes out and finds the
clean version is that is that right
yeah we suggested last time something
called like bibliographical data and
maybe you could give it an ISBN and
it'll give you a formatted reference by
last time we mean five years ago yeah
okay
to make that work I have a list of
Integrations that we haven't gotten to
yet like import an interpreter
yeah that's nice
that seems very useful so you can just
copy something from some paper and
um
uh
and it will canonicalize it with the
symbolic form
now how would this work does this work
by going to a central database on the
web to look all this stuff up
once well I mean balka presumably has
the one for isbns in the US
I don't know whether that's I don't know
whether there's a
how would this work I mean you've
written this here but how would it work
or do you not know I mean please please
say I I do not know okay I think for
various cases uh there are lookups but
not try everything
yeah I agree
right how about the next time we do this
we include Aaron and uh
started the most relevant person who
will know this kind of stuff
but so
you know for example can this be do we
have an external identified there's an
archive link yes
okay so there again we can you know that
could be picked up from there
you know I've seen a new convention this
is an interesting one which I hadn't
seen before you know how you know like
in physics papers where there are 500
authors it'll be you know Aardvark at Al
right
well in some recent llm papers I've seen
that people just put all the names in
the references
it's kind of cool for somebody whose
name begins with W not that I've written
any papers for anybody for for 40 years
or something but um uh but have you seen
that
yes
I mean is that just an online thing or
do they print that in in journals as
well
I think there are still PRL tables where
the other name is more than a page no no
no I'm not asking that question I'm not
asking about the author I'm saying when
they cite the paper
people are not citing it as Aardvark at
Al they're citing it as Aardvark
Aardvark 2 Aardvark three you know you
know
did you understand what I'm saying that
they're giving the whole list of names
in the citations at the back
have you seen that
no
well I've seen it in the last actually
just the last few weeks a bunch of llm
papers looked like that
okay let's wrap this meeting up
okay this will be continued another time
with some additional people
okay sounds good bye